this episode is presented by supercards
it's not just any haircut it's super
cuts
[Music]
disney gave cap and tony chinese cell
phones replaced a tibetan hero with
tilda swinton and thanked prison camp
bureaucrats at the end of mulan but now
the magic kingdom will pander to the
middle kingdom by making a pretty
kick-ass martial arts movie okay it's
better than that time they dropped a
full episode of er shanghaine iron man 3
[Music]
paper
chongqi
for the very first time the mcu is
bringing a martial arts master from the
comics to the screen
yep the very first time the iron fist la
la la la la
as audiences finally get to know
shanghai a guy whose most relatable
quality is that he's also getting to
know chongqi who are you your mother
knew who she was do you who the hell are
you i'm not
who you think i am
just like spider-man he's a parker with
a secret identity because underneath his
obligatory abs beats the heart of a
martial arts master
martial arts expert
martial arts enthusiast but nothing will
come between this one punch man child
and the ultimate power fantasy no not
joining the avengers kicking your
father's ass
punch
the mcu's greatest threat has returned
bad dads tony long shines as the most
seamless example yet of digitally
de-aged actors what do you mean he still
looks like that wow not bad kneel before
this ancient warlord who still doesn't
know the difference between rings and
bracelets who gave up all his power for
a lady who blew him in the woods
in addition to his ten magic bracelets
he also commands the ten rings a secret
group like hydra or shield or sword or
the scrolls or the hand or the eternals
but what sets them apart from marvel's
other illuminatis and presumably
marvel's illuminati is that the ten
rings provide exciting new opportunities
in the world of evil franchising he
appropriated the ten rings my tan rings
open up a ten rings in a country near
you we're more than just an evil
franchise we're an evil family twenty
percent cash down payment required
journey to tahloe presumably the
inspiration for ancient chinese legends
ancient middle earth legends
and legendary pokemon for a film that
blends the action comedy of a jackie
chan flick with a high-flying combat of
wusha and the cgi toilet slurry of a
marvel third act
because while an emotional expertly
choreographed martial arts showdown
between father and son is cool isn't it
way cooler when a bunch of weightless
polygons smash into each other no then
why does it keep happening
sean won't have to fight alone he's
joined by his sister ja ling who learned
to fight just by auditing classes at
murder university trevor slatterly who
pissed nerds off so much in iron man 3
that his only friend is a psychic
chicken made out of butts where's his
face
psychic by chicken
and aquafina who pulls off four classic
marvel roles at the same time platonic
love interest reaction face giver
the that just happened sidekick a guy
with a freaking machete foreign arm just
chopped our butts in half shawn used the
ten rings to like do this like crazy
kamehameha fireball that exploded the
thing that dragon
vomited a magical water map
and now i have no idea what's real and
hawkeye
upgrade
so for a franchise whose roots are an
openly racist money grab enjoy a film
that does its part to smash those
stereotypes except the one about asian
dudes being the biggest sneaker heads in
this solid martial arts fantasy flick
full of fun characters that refreshingly
stands on its own without resorting to
crossovers and team ups until after the
credits of course they don't match any
artifacts from our codex they're not
vibranium not like any alien tech i've
seen this could have been an email
starring
destiny's child soldier
ring pop
house of flying swagger the human
calendar we've been friends for 10 years
okay you know i'm not an idiot i've been
by your side for half your life your dad
trained you to be an assassin when you
were seven he sent you on a hit
at 14. can you punch with all the colors
of the wind deputy dog
i'm sorry your name is it's razor fist
and ma'am
render the last dragon your soul is mine
a normal day on the sf metro and how
marvel casts its male heroes
love that guy
i'll take your shirt off
once upon a time in a china adjacent
pocket dimension
hmm so shanghi works with cars he's not
proud of who he used to be and he has a
difficult relationship with his dad
something about that backstory seems
convenient hey screen junkies before
hawkeye comes out we decided to check
the career stats on three of cinema's
greatest archers who's the best bowman
of all time yeah we all know it's gonna
be legolas but how much better is he
than hawkeye or cadmus click the
thumbnail on the right to find out in an
all new episode of buy the numbers
this episode was presented by supercards
the smarter easier way to get a haircut
it's not just any haircut it's super
cuts check in today on our mobile app or
supercuts.com
i like chicken nachos on thanksgiving
skidamarink a dink a dink skidamarink
ado i love you